hey guys what's up this is andrew for
simpsons.com so in this video guys i'm
going to go through everything that is
happening in the global market we're
going to discuss spy triple q the u.s 10
years yield and the oil market so let's
get into it
[Music]
all right guys so uh like i said we're
gonna discuss the major indicators that
are giving us information about what is
happening right now in the world guys
there is a war you're aware of that so
inflation is coming guys so if you want
to have information about in inflation
you check the u.s 10-year yield
like i said in my last video yes the u.s
10-year yield is right now
close to two percent guys so this is a
good indicator for inflation so traders
are pricing that inflation is increasing
once again guys technical analysis
applies totally here and we have a
resistance guys at 187
and we are breaking out above that right
guys if we have a clear breakout i can
tell you that it's not going to be
looking good and that it would generate
a strong move down on the global market
now oh quickly guys same thing this is
the long-term view guys a weekly chart
i'm gonna do spy right now but this is
important yes because once again if you
want to have information about the
global market you need to have
information about the global economy and
you need to check the uh some major
indicators today what is important is
inflation and of course community prices
which is related and those two assets
are giving us good information so oil
has broken out guys above 95 i gave you
by the way that's in my discord guys and
right now it is just pulling back but
guys
i don't believe
we're not gonna go higher right i think
we're gonna go higher unfortunately it's
not gonna be good for inflation it's not
gonna be good for many things but the
very interesting question is what is
jerome powell going to do uh i mean the
fed is going to do about the rate
decision because you guys understand
that there is on one hand the war is
creating inflation which
pushes the fed to increase the pace of
the rate hike and on the other hand it's
impacting the global growth on the
downside i mean it's
it has a negative impact on the global
growth so if the growth is not here we
need to have lower rates so the fed will
decide in which direction they will go
and this is key guys even if there is a
war if the fed is accommodative and
giving low
interest rates the market is going to be
bullish right so this is very important
i don't know what's going to happen of
course i'm just giving you some
indicator you can have a look at now
let's go back to sp why guys so in my
last video i said that as always guys
i'm saying that 405 is i think the
bottom i'm not sure we're gonna reach it
but i think we will i think some of you
misunderstood just by reading the titles
but guys don't read only the titles
watch the video because i've been guys
bearish on the spy for the past two
months and those who are with me on
discord know that because you see the
trades i'm taking and they are very
straight of course uh i by the way
managed to take a short position here
but it wasn't on triple q i'm going to
show you later but right now what is
going to happen here so we can see that
bears and control okay definitely we are
in the move down this move down looks
incomplete four or five looks like it is
a possible button i'm not saying we're
gonna go there but if we go there it's a
very nice buying area for now we are
still uh developing on the downside i
think we're missing one wave guys so i
think we would go to 405
uh maybe this week i hope not but this
is a scenario but the positive thing
guys and it was spotted very nicely by a
discord member is that this move is
happening for now on decreasing volume
okay you can see we are here moving
lower but on decreasing volume so let's
see if we keep grounding lower on
decreasing volume which is exactly what
we have before reversals so if we do see
that
it would look very good on top of that
we have the macd going higher rsi going
higher so arista will probably come to
bottom so maybe we're going to have an
exaggerated divergence like it was
spotted once again on my discord by a
member it's a very good analysis but the
macd might give us a bullish uh
divergence which means the market is
making lower lows and the momentum is
making higher lows so let's see but if
we have a buddhist divergence lower
volume and we come to 405 guys it's a
massive buy all right and i'm gonna buy
here whatever happens because i'm short
so i'm gonna buy back my shorts uh if we
come here which doesn't mean we can go
no we cannot go lower but the only
signal that will tell me that uh the
market is really entering a stronger
correction is if we arrive on 405 with
very big volume all right if this
happens it will not be looking good but
i don't think it can happen for now i
think the situation is very much under
control and let's see what the fed is
going to tell us
triple q guys same situation so i'm
still having my drawings for last time
so triple q guys so as you can see we
moved lower i personally took a short
position here guys around 335 those who
are with me in this code know that uh i
had already a short position on the spy
uh i took profit here on trip on s
triple q
and i reloaded uh here all right and i
was of course short uh since here guys
so i i took this move down i took
profits here then
i didn't have any position here and here
i took a short position on
thursday or yeah thursday probably so
right now i'm short here and i'm not
gonna take profits
uh too early guys because i think we can
go to 305 this is my target just like
for spy this is the equivalent level and
once again guys volume very important
guys we need to pay attention to the
volume for now it's a decreasing volume
which means that uh bulls will easily
make a reversal happen all right if we
have increasing volume it's not going to
be easy for bulls so here we are
increasing volume so this is telling us
that we're in the middle of something so
probably going to go through 305 this is
unfortunately my preferred scenario but
let's see hopefully i'm going to be
wrong because it's never good to see the
global market thanking once again for
amcg we need the global market to be
back that's why i'm making these updates
guys because it's very important you
need to pay attention to what is
happening here
and once we reach that bottom hopefully
guys uh the bull market is gonna start
again and what is interesting is to know
if uh you have here two different
options you can buy low right around the
305 or you can wait because you don't
want to get trapped in here if we go
lower and wait for a breakout to happen
on the upside and this is what i'm going
to be discussing guys in my webinar
which is a free webinar so just click on
the link in the description of this
video it's on march 16th 12 p.m eastern
time guys so come there massively guys
it's going to be very interesting i'm
going to be discussing what is
the different strategies you can use to
manage a swing trading portfolio i'm
doing that for flow bank which is uh
because i know the ceo assistant which
is the wife of my cousin guys so this is
the little story behind that and they
invited me to be a speaker so of course
i said yes because i think it's very
interesting to spread this information
to as many people as possible so guys
come there subscribe to this link it's
gonna be very interesting for you and
yeah so that's pretty much it guys uh um
slightly bearish for this week 307 and
four or five are my levels for the
bottom of this correction uh we need to
check what is happening on the volume we
need to check what is happening on the
volatility
uh we can monitor uh the u.s 10 year
yield if we start to move above two for
more than one or two days guys it will
not be looking good we can monitor as
well the oil market if we come back to
95 guys it's a massive buy to me and if
we start to fly guys it's of course not
good for the market because it's
creating inflation and this is once
again just a forecast of traders
it's not directly
the inflation it's just what traders
think so it's a speculation on the
future inflation but it's very good
information to add up to the analysis
we're doing on the rest of the market so
that's it for me i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to click on the sub like and bell
button so you're to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore see you guys